هذه دبابه قتاليه تعود لحقبه الاتحاد
السوفيتي تم تصميمها في سنوات السبعينيات
هذا الجندي الاوكراني الذي يعمل ضمن طاقم
الدبابه يعتبر ان هذه الدبابه قد تجاوزها
الزمن مبديا امتعاضه الشديد من تردد
المانيا في الترخيص للدول الاوروبيه
بتسليم اكياف دبابات ليوبارد اثنان
الالمانيه الصنع
الدبابات الامريكي
تمتلك تجهيزات حديثه ودروعها تحمي بشكل
جيد وهذا امر مهم للبقاء على قيد الحياه
كجندي يقاتل داخل الدبابه
هذه الوحده فقدت ثمانيه دبابات هجوميه
خلال المعارك الاخيره ضد القوات الروسيه
وعددا كبيرا من اطقمها قائد الوحده لا
يقدم رقما عن القتلى لكنه مقتنع ان
الدبابات الجيل الجديد ستحد من حجم
الخسائر البشريه كما لا يخفي ان هذا
المدفع التقليدي والتجهيزات القديمه لن
تسمح لهم بتحقيق الانتصار تجهيزات
الدبابات الحديثه رقميه واليكترونيه سواء
تعلق الامر باجهزه الرؤيه والرمي والاشاره
وخزانات الذخيره حيث تمنح فعاليه ناريه
كبيره لتدمير الاهداف المعاديه وسرعه في
الحركه والمناوره اثناء المعركه وهذا ما
ينقص الدبابات الاوكرانيه التي تكتفي
بالدفاع عن مواقعها بعناء كبير